que esas tres cosas juntas.
Es un arma de destrucción masiva muy potente.
Y el costo para el mundo es inmenso:
USD 260 000 millones perdidos cada año
debido a la falta de saneamiento.
Estas son camas de cólera en Haití.
Han escuchado sobre el cólera, pero no escuchamos sobre la diarrea.
Tiene una fracción de la atención y financiación
dada a cualquiera de esas otras enfermedades.
Pero sabemos cómo arreglarlo.
Lo sabemos, porque a mediados del siglo XIX,
los maravillosos ingenieros victorianos
instalaron sistemas de alcantarillas y tratamiento de aguas residuales
y el inodoro y las enfermedades se redujeron dramáticamente.
La mortalidad infantil se redujo
como nunca se había reducido antes.
El inodoro fue votado como el mejor avance médico
de los últimos 200 años por los lectores de la British Medical Journal
y lo eligieron por sobre la píldora, la anestesia
y la cirugía.
Es un dispositivo de eliminación de desechos maravilloso.
Pero creo que es tan bueno, no tiene olor,
lo podemos colocar en nuestra casa, podemos colocarlo detrás de una puerta
y creo que también lo hemos dejado fuera de las conversaciones.
No le tenemos una palabra neutral.
"Popó" no es particularmente adecuada.
"Mierda" ofende a la gente. "Heces" es demasiado médica.
Porque no puedo explicar de otra manera,
cuando veo las cifras, lo que está pasando.
Sabemos cómo resolver el problema de la diarrea y el saneamiento,
pero si miran a los presupuestos de los países,
en desarrollo y desarrollados,
creerán que hay algo mal con los cálculos,
porque esperarían cosas absurdas como
que Pakistán gasta 47 veces más en su ejército
que en agua y saneamiento,
a pesar de que 150 000 niños mueren de diarrea
en Pakistán cada año.
Pero cuando ven a ese ya minúsculo
presupuesto para agua y saneamiento
y de un 75 % a 90 % irá al suministro de agua potable,
lo que es genial, todos necesitamos agua.
Nadie va a rechazar el agua potable.
Pero la letrina humilde o el inodoro
reducen las enfermedades dos veces más
que solo colocar agua potable.
Piénsenlo. Ese pequeño niño
que corre de vuelta a su casa,
puede tener un suministro de agua fresca lindo y limpio,
pero tiene las manos sucias con las que contaminará su suministro de agua.
Y creo que el verdadero desperdicio de los desechos humanos
es que los estamos desaprovechando como un recurso
y como un increíble desencadenante para el desarrollo,
porque hay un par de cosas que los inodoros
y el popó pueden hacer por nosotros.
Un inodoro puede hacer que una chica vuelva a la escuela.
25 % de las niñas en India abandonan la escuela
porque no tienen servicios sanitarios adecuados.
Están acostumbradas a sentarse durante las clases
por años y años manteniéndolo.
Todos lo hemos hecho, pero ellas lo hacen todos los días
y cuando llegan a la pubertad y comienzan a menstruar,
es demasiado.
Y lo comprendo. ¿Quién podría culparlas?
Si conocieran a un pedagogo y le dijeran
"puedo mejorar las tasas de asistencia escolar un 25 %
solo con una sencilla cosa",
harían muchos amigos en la educación.
Esa no es la única cosa que puede hacer por ustedes.
El popó puede cocinar su cena.
Tiene nutrientes.
Nosotros ingerimos nutrientes y también los excretamos.
No los guardamos todos.
En Ruanda, están obteniendo
el 75 % del combustible para cocinar en su sistema penitenciario
del contenido de los intestinos de los presos.
Este es un grupo de internos en una prisión de Butare.
Son internos genocidas, la mayoría de ellos,
y están revolviendo los contenidos de sus propias letrinas,
porque si colocan el popó en un ambiente cerrado, en un depósito,
muy parecido a un estómago,
entonces, muy parecido a un estomago, emite gas
y pueden cocinar con él.
Y pueden creer que es solo buen karma
ver a estos hombres revolver mierda,
pero también es bueno desde un punto de vista económico,
porque están ahorrando un millón de dólares por año.
Están reduciendo la deforestación
y han encontrado un suministro de combustible que es inagotable,
infinito y gratuito al punto de producción.
No solo en la población de bajos recursos el popó puede salvar vidas.
Acá está una mujer que está a punto de recibir una dosis
de la cosa marrón en esas jeringas,
que es lo que creen que es,
aunque no del todo, porque en realidad es donada.
Ahora hay una nueva profesión llamada donante heces.
Es como el nuevo donante de esperma.
Porque ha estado sufriendo de una superbacteria llamada Clostridium difficile
y es resistente a los antibióticos en muchos casos.
La ha estado sufriendo durante años.
Ella recibe una dosis de heces humanas sanas
y la tasa de curación para este procedimiento es de 94 %.
Es impresionante, pero casi nadie continúa haciéndolo.
Quizás es el factor asco.
Está bien, porque hay un equipo de investigadores
en Canadá que han creado una muestra de heces,
una muestra falsa de heces que se llama RePOOPulate.
Estarán pensando ahora, está bien, la solución es simple,
démosle a todos un inodoro.
Y aquí es donde se pone realmente interesante,
porque no es así de sencillo, porque no somos sencillos.
El trabajo realmente interesante y emocionante,
esta es la parte atractiva, en materia de saneamiento es que
necesitamos entender la psicología humana.
Necesitamos comprender el software
como también darle a alguien el hardware.
Han encontrado en muchos países en desarrollo
que los gobiernos han entrado y dado letrinas gratis
y vuelto pocos años después y encontraron
que tienen nuevos cobertizos de cabras, templos o habitaciones libres
con sus dueños felices caminando delante de ellos
y acercándose a la tierra de defecación al aire libre.
Así que la idea es manipular las emociones humanas.
Se ha hecho por décadas. Las empresas de jabón lo hicieron
a principios del siglo XX.
Intentaron vender el jabón como algo saludable. Nadie lo compró.
Intentaron venderlo como algo sexy. Todos lo compraron.
En India ahora hay una campaña
que convence a las jóvenes novias
a no casarse con un miembro de una familia que no tenga inodoro.
Se llama "Sin baño no acepto"
(Risas)
Y en caso de que piensen que ese cartel es solo propaganda,
acá está Priyanka, de 23 años.
La conocí el pasado Octubre en India,
ella creció en un ambiente conservador.
Creció en una aldea rural, en un área pobre de India,
y se comprometió a las 14 y luego a los 21
se mudó la casa de sus suegros.
Se horrorizó al llegar y darse cuenta
de que no tenían inodoro.
Ella creció con una letrina.
No era gran cosa, pero era una letrina.
Y a la primera noche que pasó ahí, le dijeron
que a las 4 de la madrugada,
su suegra la despertó, le dijo que saliera
y fuera a hacerlo en la oscuridad al aire libre.
Y se asustó. Estaba asustada de que hubiera borrachos por ahí.
Estaba asustada de las serpientes. Estaba asustada de que la violaran.
Después de tres días, ella hizo lo impensable.
Se fue.
Y si saben algo sobre la India rural,
sabrán hacer eso es una cosa indescriptiblemente valiente.
Pero no solo eso.
Ella obtuvo su inodoro y ahora va
por todas las otras aldeas de India
convenciendo a otras mujeres a hacer lo mismo.
Es lo que llamo contagio social y es realmente poderoso
y realmente emocionante.
Otra versión de esto, otra aldea de India
cerca de donde vive Priyanka
está esta aldea, llamada Lakara, y aproximadamente hace un año
no tenía inodoros en absoluto.
Los niños morían de diarrea y cólera.
Algunos visitantes fueron, usaron variados trucos para cambiar el comportamiento
como colocar un plato de comida y un plato de excremento
y mirar como las moscas van de uno al otro.
De alguna manera, la gente que había estado pensando
que lo que hacían no era desagradable en absoluto
de pronto pensaron "¡Uy!".
No solo eso, sino que estuvieron ingiriendo el excremento de sus vecinos.
Eso es lo que realmente les hizo cambiar su comportamiento.
Así que esta mujer, esta madre del chico
instaló esta letrina en pocas horas.
Su vida entera había estado usando el campo de bananas de atrás,
pero instaló la letrina en unas pocas horas.
No cuesta nada. Va a salvar la vida de ese chico.
Así que cuando me deprimo sobre el estado del saneamiento,
a pesar de que estos son tiempos muy emocionantes,
porque tenemos la Fundación Bill y Melinda Gates
reinventando el inodoro, lo que es genial;
tenemos a Matt Damon yendo a huelga por el baño,
lo que es genial para la humanidad, muy malo para su colon.
Pero hay cosas por las que preocuparse.
Está lejos de los Objetivos de Desarrollo del Milenio.
Está a aproximadamente 50 o más años lejos.
No vamos a alcanzar los objetivos,
proporcionándole servicios sanitarios a la gente a esta velocidad.
Así que cuando me entristezco por el tema del saneamiento,
pienso en Japón, porque Japón hace 70 años
era una nación de gente que usaba letrinas de pozo
y se limpiaba con palos
y ahora es una nación de lo que se llama "woshurettos",
inodoros washlet.
Tienen boquillas de bidet incorporadas para una experiencia
en la limpieza encantadora y con manos libres
y tienen varias otras características,
como el asiento con calefacción y un dispositivo automático para subir la tapa
que se conoce como el "salvador de matrimonios".
(Risas)
Pero lo más importante, lo que han hecho en Japón,
lo que encuentro inspirador,
es que han sacado el baño de ese cuarto cerrado.
Lo han hecho un tema de conversación.
La gente va y moderniza su inodoro.
Hablan de ello. Lo han desinfectado.
Espero que podamos hacer eso. No es una cosa difícil de hacer.
Todo lo que tenemos que hacer
es ver este tema
como el tema urgente y vergonzoso que es.
Y no crean que es solo en la población de bajos recursos del mundo en que las cosas están mal
Nuestros alcantarillas están desmoronando.
Las cosas están mal aquí también.
La solución para todo esto es bastante fácil.
Voy a hacer sus vidas más fáciles esta tarde
y solo les pediré que hagan una cosa
y es que salgan, protesten,
hablen de lo inexpresable,
y hablen sucio.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)